i think you guys should play one hand of
right right okay
what happened right now right wow
okay
[Music]
this could be brutal so yeah yeah should
we play five minutes then
yeah okay or billet
five minutes
okay
and this is regular chest and not uh
this is not atomic
it's i got matter yeah right famous
the famous one pong wow finally we'll
get some views on this video can't
probably also
pump okay
but he had beef with peter not
but i think they're friends now they
both enjoy
well this is boring and night
okay
mate
thank you very much
[Music]
well bomb
let's just grab all his pawns i think
yeah
he's probably too excited yeah bishop
this can end careers i got mature i have
one viral video it's where magnus trolls
me and beats me in like 18 moves in a
dash
so you better be nervous bishop
not h6 anywhere else
uh king uh yeah looking for that one
i was thinking maybe castle on this one
feel like we're playing a bit too
passively no it's that's fine
um
there we go there we go yes exactly
just for context what's your chest level
more or less
1900 to the rating
all right nice so agar matra is like
2100 in phila i'm not sure i hope i'm
not saying
something wrong maybe 200 okay maybe
so on average your team is slightly
higher rated yeah
bishop
[Music]
knight
yeah it's starting to look pretty pretty
ugly yeah it is
bishop
let's just flag him
oh he's playing fast that's the very
least yeah
it's not playing so well but all right
bishop
this is good yeah that was the plan
right there yeah
other decent bishop move yeah i don't
think so
hinting at d5 for those who
shouldn't spoil it for him because
all right
pawn room for it
going for the king
all right
temple moves i like that
all right let's go for
a rook
let's starting to
yeah this is just domination yeah sorry
also you're not giving magnus a chance
to make a mistake like yeah
it's like very important okay what
you're gonna do
that's the trick you gotta like do the
pieces that only have one move
yeah because then it makes it easier for
me yeah
don't have the thing so
okay to look pretty ugly
all right let's go for uh
[Music]
just gonna find the mater
[Music]
too many good options yeah yeah it is
yeah let's not get flagged let's just uh
knight
gonna be pragmatic yeah okay that's not
gonna be
all right not
the easy not the easiest solutions what
what's going on here all right yeah of
course uh
night here we go here we go this is
beautiful it's gonna be another
picturesque finish i think i'm gonna
pick yeah
the chess24 chat wants your name your
age your birth certificate like all the
info you're willing to share
and now mine or his okay
there we go